The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Today, we are going
to do computational complexity.
This is rather different
from every other thing
we've seen in this class.
This class is basically about
polynomial time algorithms
and problems where we
can solve your problem
in polynomial time.
And today, it's about
when you can't do that.
Sometimes, we can prove
you can't do that.
Sometimes, we're pretty
sure you can't do that.
But it's all about
negative results
when your problems
are really complex.
And there's a lot
of fun topics, here.
This is the topic of
entire classes, like 6045.
We're just going to get
a 1 hour flavor of it.
So think of it as
a high level intro.
But we're going to prove real
theorems and do real things
and you'll get a sense
of how all this works.
So I'm going to start out with
three complexity classes--
P, EXP, and R. How many
people know what P is?
And it is?
Polynomial time.
More precisely, it's
the set of all problems
you can solve in
polynomial time.
This is what the
class is all about.
Almost every
problem we have seen
in this class-- there's
one exception-- is
in P. Does anyone
know the exception?
It's a good puzzle for you.
Not NP.
What's next?
EXP.
How many people
know what EXP is?
Or you can guess.
Any guesses?
Exponential.
These are all the problems you
can solve in exponential time.
If you want to be formal
about it, in this case,
exponential means 2 to
the n to some constant.
So not just 2 the n, but also
2 to the n squared, 2 to the n
cubed.
Those are all
considered-- exponential
and a polynomial is
considered in the class EXP.
Now, basically, almost every
problem you can dream of you
can solve in EXP.
Exponential time
is so much time.
And this class has always
been about taking things that
are obviously in EXP and showing
that they're actually in P.
So if you want to
draw a picture,
you could say, OK,
here's all the problems
we can solve in polynomial time.
Here's all the problems we
can solve in exponential time.
And there are problems out here.
These are different classes.
And we want to sort
of bring things
into here as much as possible.
I actually want to
draw this picture
in a different way, which
is as a horizontal line.
So an axis.
I'm going to call this
computational difficulty.
You could call it
computational complexity,
but that's a bit of
a loaded term that
actually has formal meaning.
Difficulty is nice and vague.
So I can draw an
abstract picture.
This is not a true
diagram, but it's
a very good guideline
of what's going on.
So we have-- I'm going to draw--
I believe-- three notches.
No, eventually four, so let
me give myself some room.
We have over here, the
easy problems are P. Then,
we have these problems,
which are EXP.
We're going to fill in
something in the middle.
And then this is
something called R.
So you've got P is
everything, here.
EXP is all the way out to
here, in some abstract view.
The next thing is R. How
many people know what R is?
This one, I had to look up.
It's not usually given a name.
No one.
Teaching staff?
You guys know it?
These are all problems
solvable in finite time.
R stands for finite.
R stands for recursive.
Recursive used to mean
something completely different,
back in the '30s, when people
were thinking about what's
computable, what's
not computable.
These are, basically, solvable
problems, computable problems.
Finite time is a reasonable
requirement, I think,
for all algorithms.
And that's R. Now,
I've drawn this arrow
to keep going because there
are problems out here.
It's kind of
discouraging, but there
are problems that
are unsolvable.
In fact, most problems
We're going to prove that.
It's actually really
easy to prove.
Kind of depressing, but true.
Let me start with some examples
before we get to that proof.
So I'm writing examples
of some things we've seen.
So here's an example of
a problem we've seen.
Negative-weight cycle detection.
I give you a graph--
a weighted graph.
I want to know does it have
any negative-weight cycles?
What classes is this problem in?
P. We know how to solve
this in polynomial time--
in VE time-- using Bellman-Ford.
VE time-- well, that finds
negative-weight cycles
reachable from s.
But, I guess, if you
add a source that
can reach anywhere--
zero weight-- then
that'll tell you
overall that it's in P.
It's also in EXP, of course.
Everything in P is also in EXP.
Because if you can solve
it in polynomial time,
you can solve it in
exponential time.
This is at most
At most polynomial.
Here's a problem
we haven't seen.
But it's pretty cool.
N by n Chess.
So this is the
problem I give you.
So we're in an by n
board, and I give you
a whole bunch of
pieces on the board,
and I want to know does
White win from here?
I say it's White to
move or Black to move,
and who's going to win
form this position?
This problem, can be
solved in exponential time.
You can sort of play out
all possible strategies
and see who wins.
And it's not in P. There's
no polynomial time algorithm
to play generalized Chess.
This sort of captures why
Chess-- even at eight by eight
Chess-- is hard-- because
there's no general way
to do it.
So there's no special
way to do it, probably.
Computational complexity is
all about order of growth.
So we can't analyze
eight by eight Chess,
but we can analyze n by n Chess.
And that gives us a flavor of
why 8 by 8 is so difficult.
Go is also in EXP, but
not in P-- lots of games
are in this category, lot's of
complicated games, let's say.
And so this is a first example
of a problem that we know we
cannot solve in polynomial time.
Bad news.
I also talked about
Tetris a little bit.
Unlike the Tetris
training, which we saw,
this is sort of
realistic Tetris--
all the rules of Tetris.
The only catch is that I
tell you all the pieces that
are going to come in advance.
Because, otherwise,
it's some random process
and it's kind of hard to think
about what's the best strategy.
But if I tell you
what's going to come--
say it's a
pseudo-random generator
and you know how it works.
You know all the
pieces that will come.
I want to know can I survive
from a given initial board mess
and for a given
sequence of pieces.
This can also be solved
in exponential time.
Just try all the possibilities.
We don't know whether it's
in P. We're pretty sure
it's not in P. And by the
end of today's lecture,
you'll understand why
we think it's not in P.
But it's going to be
somewhere in between here.
Tetris is actually right here.
But I haven't defined
what right here is yet.
And then the next one
is halting problem.
So halting problem
is particularly cool,
as we'll see-- or interesting.
It's the problem of given a
computer program-- Python,
whatever, it doesn't really
matter what language.
They're all the same in
a theoretical sense--
does it ever halt?
Does it ever stop running,
return a result, whatever?
This would be really handy--
you're writing some code,
and you've run it
for 5 hours, and you
don't know is that
because there's a bug
and you've got an infinite loop?
Or is it just because
it's really slow?
So you'd like to give it
to some program-- checking
program-- that says
will this run forever
or will it terminate.
That's the halting problem.
And this problem
is not in R. There
is no correct algorithm
for solving this problem.
There's no way to tell,
given an arbitrary program,
whether it will halt.
Now, in some situations--
take the empty program--
I can tell that it halts.
Or I take some special
simple class of programs,
I can tell whether they halt or
determine that they don't halt.
But there's no algorithm that
solves it for all programs,
in finite time.
In infinite time,
I can solve it.
Just run it.
Run the program.
Given finite time, there's
no way to solve this.
And so this is a little bit
beyond what we can prove today.
It's not that hard
to prove, but it
takes half an hour or something.
I want to get to other things.
But if you take 6045,
they'll prove this.
What I want to show you
instead is an easier
result-- that almost
every problem is not in R.
I need one term, though,
which is decision problems.
All of these problems,
I set it up in a way
that the answer is
binary-- yes or no.
Is there a
negative-weight cycle?
Yes or no?
Does White win from
this position in Chess?
Can you survive in Tetris?
And does this program halt?
For various reasons--
basically convenience--
the whole field of
computational complexity
focuses on decision problems.
And, in fact-- so
decision problems
are ones where the
answer is yes or no.
That's all.
Why?
Essentially because
it doesn't matter.
If you take a problem
you care about,
you can convert it into
a decision problem.
We can see examples
of that later.
Decision problems
are basically as
hard as optimization
problems or whatever.
But let's focus on
decision problems.
The answer is yes or no.
Claim that most of
them are uncomputable.
And we can prove
this pretty easily
if you know a bit of
set theory, I guess.
On the one hand, I have
problems I want to solve.
These are decision problems.
And on the other hand,
I have algorithms,
or computer programs
to solve them.
I'm going to think
of computer programs
because more precise
algorithms can
be a little bit nebulous for
thinking about pseudocode--
what's valid, what's invalid.
But computer programs
are very clear.
I give you some code.
You throw it into Python.
Either it works or it doesn't.
And it does something.
Runs for a while.
How can I think about the
space of all possible programs?
Well, programs are things
you type into a computer
in ASCII, whatever.
In the end, you can think of
it as just as a binary string.
Somehow it gets
encoded in binary.
Everything is reduced to binary
in the end, on a computer.
So this is a binary string.
Now, you can also think
of a binary string
as representing a
number, in binary.
So you can also
think of a program,
then, as a natural number-- some
number between 0 and infinity.
And an integer.
So usually we represent
this as math bold N.
That's just 0, 1, 2, 3.
You can think of every
program is ultimately
reducing to an integer.
It's a big integer, but, hey.
It's an integer.
So that's the space
of all programs.
Now, I want to think about the
space of all decision problems.
So how can I define
a decision problem?
Well, the natural way to
think of a decision problem
is as a function that
maps inputs to yes or no.
Function from
inputs to yes or no.
Or you can think
of that as 1 and 0.
So what's an input?
Well, an input is
a binary string.
So an input is a number--
a natural number.
Input is a binary string, which
we can think of as being in N.
So we've got a
function from N to 0,1.
So another way to represent
one of these functions
is as a table.
I could just write
down all the answers.
So I've got, well, the input
could be 0-- the number 0.
And then, maybe it's a 0.
Input could be could be 1
and then, maybe, output is 0.
Then, the input could be 2,
3, 4, 5, 1, 0, 1, 1, whatever.
So I could write the
table of all answers.
This is another way to
write down such a function.
What we have, here, is an
infinite string of bits.
Each of them could be 0 or 1.
It would be a different problem.
But they all exist.
Any infinite string of bits
represents a decision problem.
They're the same thing.
So a decision problem is
an infinite string of bits.
A program is a finite
string of bits.
These are different things.
One way to see that
they're different
is put a decimal point, here.
Now, this infinite
string of bits
is a number-- a real
number-- between 0 and 1.
It's written in binary.
You may not be used
to binary point.
This dot is not a decimal point.
It's a binary point.
But, hey.
Any real number can be expressed
by an infinite string of bits
in this way-- any real
number between 0 and 1.
So a decision
problem is basically
something in R, the set
of all real numbers,
whereas a program is something
in N, the set of all integers.
And the thing is, the
number of real numbers
is much, much bigger than
the number of integers.
In a formal sense, we call
this one uncountably infinite,
and this one is
countably infinite.
I'm not going to prove
that here, today.
You may have seen that proof.
It's pretty simple.
And that's bad news.
That means that there
are way more problems
than there are
programs to solve them.
So this means almost every
problem that we could conceive
of is unsolvable
by every program.
And this is pretty depressing
the first time I saw it.
That's why we put it at
the end of the class.
I think you get all existential.
I mean the thing is
every program only
solves one problem.
It takes some input,
and it's either
going to output yes or no.
And if it's wrong on any of
the inputs, then it's wrong.
So it's going to give an answer.
Say it's a
deterministic algorithm.
No random numbers or things.
Then, there's just
not enough programs
to go around if each program
only solves one problem.
This is the end of the proof.
Any questions about that?
Kind of weird.
Because yet somehow, most of
the problems that we think about
are computable.
I don't know why that is.
But mathematically,
most problems
that you could think
of are uncomputable.
Question?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
It's something like,
the way that we describe
problems is usually almost
algorithmic, anyway.
And so, usually, most problems
we think of are in EXP.
And so they're
definitely computable.
There's some
metatheorem about how
we think about problems,
not just programs.
So that's all I'm going to
say about R. So out here,
we have halting problem and,
actually, most problems.
You can think of this
as an infinite line
and then there's just
this small portion
which are things you can solve.
But we care about this
portion because that's
the interesting stuff.
That's what
algorithms are about.
Out here kind of
nothing happens.
So I want to talk about
this notch, which is NP.
I imagine you've heard about NP.
It's pretty cool, but
also kind of confusing.
But it's actually very
closely related to something
we've seen with dynamic
programming, which is guessing.
So I'm going to give you
a couple of definitions
of NP-- not formal definition,
but high level definitions.
So just like P, EXP, and R,
it's a set of decision problems.
And it's going to look very
similar to P. NP does not
stand for not a polynomial.
It stands for
nondeterministic polynomial.
We'll get to
nondeterministic in a moment.
The first line is the same.
It's all decision problems you
can solve in polynomial time.
That sounds like P.
But then, there's
this extra line, which is
via a "lucky" algorithm.
Let me tell you--
at a high level what
a lucky algorithm does
is it can make guesses.
But unlike the way that
we've been making guesses
with dynamic programming--
with dynamic programming
we had to guess something.
We tried all the possibilities.
A lucky algorithm just
needs to try one possibility
because it's really lucky.
It always guesses
the right choice.
It's like magic.
This is not a realistic
model of computation,
but it is a model of computation
called nondeterministic model.
And it's going to sound
crazy because it is crazy,
but nonetheless it's
actually really useful--
even though you could
never really build
this on a real computer.
The nondeterministic
model is not
a model of real computation.
It is a model of theoretical
hypothetical computation.
It gets at the
root-- at the core
of what is possible to solve.
You'll see why, in a little bit.
So in this model, an algorithm--
it can compute stuff,
but, in particular,
it makes guesses.
So should I do this
or should I do this?
And it just says-- It
doesn't flip a coin.
It's not random.
It just thinks-- it
just makes a guess.
Well, I don't know.
Let's go this way.
And then it comes
another fork in the road.
It's like, well, I don't know.
I'll go this way.
That's the guessing.
You give it a list of
choices and somehow a choice
is determined, by magic--
nondeterministic magic.
And then the fun part is--
I should say, at the end
the algorithm either
says yes or no.
It gives you an output.
The guesses are guaranteed--
this is the magic part--
to lead to a yes
answer, if possible.
So if you imagine the space
of executions of this program,
you start here, and you
make some guess and you
don't know which way to go.
In dynamic programming,
we try all of them.
But this algorithm
doesn't try all of them.
It's like a branching universe
model of the universe.
So you make some
choice, and then you
make some other choice, and
then you make some other choice.
All of these are guesses.
And some of these
things will lead to yes.
Some of these things
will lead to no.
And in this magical model,
if there's any yes out there,
you will follow a path to a yes.
If all of the answers
are no, then, of course,
it doesn't matter
what choices you make.
You will output no.
But if there's ever a yes,
magically these guesses
find it.
This is the sense of lucky.
If you're trying to find a
yes-- that's your goal in life--
then this corresponds to luck.
And NP is the class of
all problems solvable
in polynomial time by a
really lucky algorithm.
Crazy.
I know.
Let's talk about Tetris.
Tetris, I claim, is in NP.
And we know how to solve
it in exponential time.
Just try all the options.
But, in fact, I don't need
to try all the options.
It would be enough just use
this nondeterministic magic.
I could say, well, should I
drop the piece here, here, here,
here, here, or here.
And should it be rotated
like this, or like this,
or like this, or like this?
I don't know.
So I guess.
And I just place that piece.
I make another guess where
to place the next piece.
Then I make another guess
where to place the next piece.
I implement the rules
of Tetris, which
is if there's a
full line it clears.
I figure out where
these things fall.
I can even think about, should
I rotate at the last second.
If I don't know, I'll guess.
Any choice you have to
make in playing Tetris,
you can just guess.
There's only polynomially
many guesses you need to make.
So it's still polynomial time.
That's important.
It's not like we
can do anything.
But we can make a polynomial
number these magic guesses.
And then at the end, I
determine did I die--
or rather, did I survive.
It's important, actually.
It only works one way.
Did I survive?
Yes or no?
And that's easy to compute.
I just see did I ever
go above the top row.
So what this model says
is if there is any way
to survive-- if there is
any way to get a yes answer,
then, my guesses will find
it, magically, in this model.
Therefore, Tetris is in NP.
If I had instead
said, did I die, then,
what this algorithm would
tell me is there any way
to die-- which, the
answer's probably yes,
unless you're given a
really trivial input.
So it's important you set up
the yes versus no, correctly.
But the Tetris decision problem
"can I survive," is in NP.
The decision problem "can I
die," should not be in NP.
But we don't know.
Another way to think about NP.
And you might find
this intuitive
because we've been
doing lots of guessing.
It's just a little crazy.
There's another way that's
more intuitive to many people.
So if this doesn't make
sense, don't worry, yet.
This is another
way to phrase it.
Another way to think
about NP-- which turns out
to be equivalent-- is that don't
think so much about algorithms
for solving a problem,
just think about algorithms
for checking the
solution to a problem.
It's usually a lot
easier to check your work
than it is to solve a
problem in the first place.
And NP is all about that issue.
So think of decision
problems and think
about if you have a solution--
so let's say in Tetris,
the solution is yes.
In fact, I need to
say this, probably.
The more formal
version is whenever
the answer is yes,
you can prove it.
And you can check that
proof in polynomial time.
This is the more formal--
this a little bit high level.
What does check mean?
Here's what check means.
Whenever an answer is "yes,"
you can write down a proof
that the answer is yes.
And someone can
come along and check
that proof in polynomial
time and be convinced
that the answer is yes.
What does convinced mean?
It's not that hard.
Think of it is a
two player game.
There's me trying
to play Tetris,
and there's you
trying to be convinced
that I'm really good at Tetris.
It seems a little one sided,
but-- it's a asymmetric game.
So you want to prove Tetris is--
I want to show Tetris is in NP.
Imagine I'm this
magical creature.
Actually, it's kind of funny.
It reminds me of a story.
On the front of my
office door, you
may have seen there's
an email I received,
maybe 15 years
ago-- oh no, I guess
it can't be that long ago.
Must've been about
7 years ago when
we proved that Tetris
is NP-complete.
And the email says, "Dear
Sir,"-- or whatever--
"I am NP-complete."
We don't what
NP-complete means, yet,
but it's a
meaningless statement.
So it doesn't matter that
you don't know what it means.
It might get funnier
throughout the lecture today.
And he's like, I
can solve Tetris.
I'm really good
at playing Tetris.
I'm really good at
playing Minesweeper--
all these games that are
thought to be intractable.
He gave me his
records and so on.
It's like how can
I apply my talent.
So I will translate what he
meant to say was, "I am lucky."
And this is probably
not true, but he
thought that he was lucky.
He wanted to convince
me he was lucky.
So how could we do it?
Well, I could give him a
really hard Tetris problem.
And say, can you
survive these pieces?
And he says, "yes,
I can survive. "
And how does he prove to
me that he can survive?
Well, he just plays it.
He shows me what to do.
So proof is sequence
of moves that you make.
It's really easy
to convince someone
that you can survive a
given level of Tetris.
You just show what the
sequence of moves are.
And then I, as a mere mortal
polynomial time algorithm
can check that that
sequence works.
I just have to implement
the rules of Tetris.
So in Tetris, the rules
are easy to implement.
Its the knowing what
thing to do is hard.
But in NP, knowing
which way to go is easy.
In this version,
you don't even talk
about how to find the solution.
It's just a matter
of can you write down
a solution that can be checked.
Can prove it.
This is not in polynomial time.
You get arbitrarily
much time to prove it.
But then, the check has to
happen in polynomial time.
Kind of clear?
That's Tetris.
And every problem that you
can solve in polynomial
time you can also,
of course, check it.
Because if you could solve
it in polynomial time,
you could just solve
it and then see
did you get the same
answer that I did.
So P is inside NP.
But the big question
is does p equal NP.
And most people think no.
P does not equal NP--
most sane people.
So this is a big problem.
It's one of the famous
Millennium Prize problems.
So in particular, if you solved
it, you would get $1 million,
and fame, and probably
other fortune.
You could do TV spots.
I think that's how people
mostly make their money.
You could do a lot.
You would become the most famous
computer scientist in the world
if you prove this.
So a lot of people have tried.
Every year, there's an
attempt to prove either
what everyone believes
or, most often,
people try to prove the
reverse-- that they are equal.
I don't know why.
They should bet the other way.
So what does P does
not equal NP mean?
It means that there are
problems, here, that are in NP
but not in P. Think
about what this means.
This is saying P are the
problems that we can actually
solve on a legitimate computer.
NP are problems that we can
solve in this magical fairy
computer where all of
our dreams are granted.
You say, oh, I don't
know which way to go.
It doesn't matter because
the machine magically
tells you which way to go.
If you're goal is
to get to a yes.
So NP is a really powerful
model of computation.
It's an insane model
of computation.
No one in their right mind
would consider it legitimate.
So obviously, it's
more powerful than P,
except we don't know
how to prove it.
Very annoying.
Other phrasings of
P does not equal
NP is-- these are my
phrasings, I them up-- you
can't engineer luck.
You can believe in
luck, if you want.
But it's not something
that we can build out
of a regular computer.
That's the meaning
of this statement.
And so I think most
people believe that.
Another phrasing would
be that solving problems
is harder than
checking solutions.
A more formal version is that
generating solutions or proofs
of solutions can be
harder than checking them.
Another phrasing is
it's harder to generate
a proof of a theorem
than it is to check
the proof of a theorem.
We all know checking
the proof of a theorem
should be easy if you
write it precisely.
Just make sure each step
follows from the previous ones.
Done.
But proving a
theorem, that's hard.
You need inspiration.
You need some clever idea.
That's guessing.
Inspiration equals luck equals
guessing, in this model.
And that's hard.
The only way we know is
to try all the proofs.
See which of them work.
So what the heck?
What could we possibly say?
This is all kind of weird.
This would be the
end of the lecture
if you say, OK,
well we don't know.
That's it.
But thankfully-- I kind
of need this board.
I also want this one, but
I guess I'll go over here.
Fortunately, this is not
the end of the story.
And we can say a lot
about things like Tetris.
See I drew Tetris not
just in this regime.
We're pretty sure Tetris
is between NP and P.
That it's in NP minus P.
So let me write that down.
Tetris is in NP minus P. We
don't know that because we
don't know-- this
could be the empty set.
What we do know
is that if there's
anything in NP minus P--
if they are different,
then-- if there's
anything in NP minus P,
then Tetris is one
of those things.
That's why I drew
Tetris out there.
It is, in a certain sense,
the hardest problem in NP.
Tetris.
Why Tetris?
Well, it's not just Tetris.
There are a lot of problems
right at that little notch.
But this is pretty interesting
because, while we can't figure
this out, most people
believe this is true.
And so as long as you
believe in that-- as long
as you have faith--
then you can prove
that Tetris is in NP minus P.
And so it's hard.
It's not in P, in this case.
In particular, not in
P. That's kind of cool.
How in the world do we
prove something like this?
It's actually not that hard.
I mean it took us
several months,
but that's just months, whereas
this thing has been around
since, I guess, the '70s.
P versus NP.
Why is this true?
Because Tetris is NP-hard.
What does NP-hard mean?
This means as hard as
every problem in NP.
I can't say harder than
because it's non-strict.
So it's at least as hard
as every problem in NP.
And that's why I drew
it at the far right.
It's sort of the
hardest extreme of NP.
Among everything in NP
you can possibly imagine,
Tetris is as hard
as all of them.
And therefore, if there's
anything that's harder than P,
then Tetris is going to be
harder than P because it's
as far to the right as possible.
Either P equals NP, in which
case the picture is like this.
Here's P. Here's NP.
Tetris is still at the
right extreme, here.
But it's less interesting
because it's still in P.
Or the picture looks like
this, and NP is strictly
bigger than P. And then, because
Tetris is at the right extreme,
it's outside of P. So
we prove this in order
to establish this claim.
Just to get some
terminology, what
is this NP-complete business?
Tetris is NP-complete,
which means two things.
One is that it's NP-hard.
And the other is
that it's in NP.
So if you think of the
intersection, NP intersect
NP-hard, that's NP-complete.
Let me draw on the picture
here what this means.
So I'm going to
draw it on the top.
This is NP-hard.
Everything from here to
the right is NP-hard.
NP-hard means it's at least
as hard as everything in NP.
That means it might
be at this line
or it might be to the right.
But in the case of Tetris,
we know that it's in NP.
We proved that a
couple of times.
And so we know that Tetris
is also in this range.
And so if it's in this
range and in this range,
it's got to be right here.
Completeness is nice.
If you prove something
is something complete--
prove a problem is some
complexity class complete--
then you know sort of exactly
where it falls on this line.
NP-complete means right here.
EXP-complete means right here.
Turns out Chess is EXP-complete.
EXP-hard is anything
from here over.
EXP is anything from
here, over this way.
Chess is right at
that borderline.
It is the hardest
problem in EXP.
And that's actually
the only way we
know to prove that it's not NP.
It's is pretty easy to
show that EXP is bigger
than P. And Chess is the
farthest to the right in EXP--
of any problem in EXP-- and
so, therefore, it's not in P.
So whereas this one-- these two,
we're not sure are they equal.
This line we know is
different from this one.
We don't know about
these two, though.
Does NP equal EXP?
Not as famous.
You won't get a million
dollars, but still a very big,
open question.
What else do I wanna say?
Tetris, Chess, EXP-hard.
So these lines, here--
this is NP-complete
And this is EXP-complete.
So the last thing I want to
talk about is reductions.
Reductions-- so how do you
prove something like this?
What is as hard as even mean?
I haven't defined that.
But it's not hard to define.
In fact, it's a concept
we've seen already.
Reductions are actually a
way to design algorithms
that we've been using
implicitly a lot.
You may have even
heard this term.
A bunch of recitations have
used the word reduction
for graph reduction.
You have some problem,
you convert it
into a graph problem, then you
just call the graph algorithm.
You're done.
That's reduction.
In general, you have
some problem, A,
that you want to solve.
And you convert it into
some other problem, B,
that you already
know how to solve.
It's a great tool
because, in this class,
you learn tons of algorithms
for solving tons of problems.
Now, someone gives you,
in your job or whatever,
or you think about
some problem that you
don't know how to solve,
the first thing you should
do is-- can I convert
it into something
I know how to solve
because then you're done.
Now it may not be the
best way to solve it,
but at least it's
a way to solve it.
Probably in polynomial time
because we think of B as things
you can solve in
polynomial time.
Great.
So just convert
problem A, which you
want to solve, into some problem
B that you know how to solve.
That's reduction.
Let me give you some examples
that we've already seen,
just to fit this into your
mental map of the class.
It's kind of a funny one
but it's a very simple one.
So how do you solve
unweighted shortest paths?
In general?
Easy one.
Give you a graph with no
weights on the edges and I
want to the shortest
path from s to t.
AUDIENCE: BFS
PROFESSOR: BFS.
Linear time, right?
Well, that's if
you're smart or if you
feel like implementing BFS.
Suppose someone
gave you Djikstra.
Said, here, look, I've
got Djikstra code.
You don't have to do anything.
There's Djisktra
code right there.
But Djikstra solves
weighted shortest path.
I don't have any weights.
What do I do?
Set the weights to 1.
It's very easy, but
this is a reduction--
a simple example of reduction.
Not the smartest of reductions,
but it's a reduction.
So I can convert
unweighted shortest paths
into weighted shortest paths
by adding weights of 1.
Done.
Adding weights of
0 would not work.
But weights of 1.
OK.
Weights of 2 also works.
Pick your favorite number, but
as long as you're consistent
about it.
That's a reduction.
Here's some more
interesting ones.
On the problems set--
problem set six--
there was this RenBook problem,
"I Can Haz Moar Frendz?"
That was the name
of the problem.
And the goal was
to solve-- to find
paths that minimize
the product of weights.
But what we've
covered in class is
how to solve a problem when
it's the sum of weights.
How do you do it?
In one word, or less?
Logs.
Just take logs.
That converts
products into sums.
Now you start to get the flavor.
This is a problem that you could
take Djikstra or Bellman-Ford,
and change all the
relaxation steps
and change it to work
directly with products.
That would work,
but it's more work.
You have to prove that
that's still correct.
It's annoying to think about.
And it's annoying to program.
It's not modular,
blah, blah, blah.
Whereas if you just
do this reduction,
you can use exactly the
code that you had before,
at the end.
So that's nice.
This is why
reductions are really
the most common algorithm design
technique because you don't
want to implement an algorithm
for every single problem you
have.
It would be nice if you could
reuse some of those algorithms
that you had before.
Reductions let you do that.
Another one, which was on the
quiz in the true-false-- quiz
two-- was converting longest
path into shortest path.
We didn't phrase
it as a reduction.
It was just can you
solve longest path using
Bellman-Ford.
And the answer is yes.
You just negate all the weights.
And that converts a
longest path problem
into a shortest path problem.
Easy.
Also on the quiz-- maybe I don't
need to write all of these down
because they're a little
bit weird problems.
We made them up.
There was the-- what was
the duck tour called?
Bird tours?
Aviation tours?
Whatever.
You want to visit a bunch of
sites in some specified order.
The point in that problem
is you could reduce it
to a single shortest
paths query.
And so if you already
have shortest path code,
you don't have to think much.
You just do the
graph application.
Done.
Then there's the
leaky tank problem,
which is also a graph
reduction problem.
You could represent all
these extra weird things
that were happening
in your car by just
changing the graph a little bit.
And it's a very
powerful technique.
In this class, we see it
mostly in graph reductions.
But it could apply
all over the place.
And while this is a powerful
technique for coming up
with new algorithms, it's
also a powerful technique
for proving things
like Tetris is NP-hard.
So what we proved
is that a problem
called 3-Partition can
be reduced to Tetris.
What's 3-Partition?
3-Partition is I
give you n numbers.
I want to know can I
divide them into triples,
each of the same sum.
So I have n numbers.
Divide them into n
over 3 groups of 3,
such that the sum of
each of the 3s is equal.
Sounds like an easy
enough problem.
But it's an NP-complete problem.
And people knew that since
one of the first papers.
I guess that was late
'70s, early '80s, by Karp.
So Karp already proved
this is standing
on the shoulders of giants.
Karp proved 3-Partition
is NP-complete,
so I don't need to
think about that.
All I need to
focus on is showing
that Tetris is harder
than 3-Partition.
This is what I mean by harder.
Harder means-- so when
I can reduce A to B,
we say the A-- B is at least
as hard as A. Why's that?
Because I can solve A by solving
B. I just apply this reduction
and then solve B. So if I
had some good way to solve B,
it would turn into a
good way to solve A.
Now 3-Partition-- which
is A, here-- we're
pretty sure there's no good
algorithm for solving this.
Pretty sure it's not in P.
And so Tetris better not be P
either because if
Tetris were in P, then
we could just take
our 3-Partition,
reduce it to Tetris, and then
3-Partition would be in P.
In fact, all of the
NP-complete problems,
you can reduce to each other.
And so to show that something
is at that little position,
NP-complete, all
you need to do is
find some known
NP-complete problem
and reduce it to your problem.
So reductions are super useful
for getting positive results
for making new
algorithms, but also
for proving negative results--
showing that one problem is
harder than another.
And if you already
believe this is hard,
then you should
believe this is hard.
I think that's all I
really have time for.
I'll give you a couple
more NP-complete problems.
Kind of fun.
Traveling salesman problem,
you may have heard of.
Let's say you have a graph.
And you want to find out
the shortest path that
visits all the vertices,
not just one vertex.
That's NP-complete.
We solved longest common
subsequence for two strings,
but if I give you
n strings that you
need to find the longest
common subsequence of,
that's NP-complete.
Minesweeper, Sudoku, most
puzzles that are interesting
are NP-complete.
SAT.
SAT is a-- I give you a Boolean
formula like x or y AND NOT
x-- something like that.
I want to know is there some
setting of the variables that
makes this thing come out true?
Is it possible to
make this true?
That's NP-complete complete.
This was actually
the first problem
that was shown NP-complete.
There's this issue, right?
If I'm going to show
everything's NP-complete
by reduction, how the
heck do I get started?
What's the first problem?
And this is the first problem.
You could sort of prove it
by definition, almost, of NP,
here.
But I won't do that.
Three coloring a graph.
Shortest paths.
This is fun.
Shortest paths in
a graph is hard.
But in the real world, we
live in a three dimensional,
geometric environment.
What if I want to
find the shortest
path from this point,
where I am, to that point,
over on the ceiling
or something.
And I can fly.
That's NP-complete.
It's kind of weird.
Shortest paths in a two
dimensional environment
is polynomial.
It's a good thing that we are
on ground because, then, we
can model things
by two dimensions.
We can model things by graphs.
But in 3D, shortest
paths is NP-complete.
So all these things where
a problem-- knapsack,
that's another one.
We've already covered knapsack.
We saw a pseudo-polynomial
algorithm.
Turns out, you can't do
better than pseudo-polynomial
unless P equals NP because
knapsack is NP-complete.
So there you go.
Computational complexity
in 50 minutes.